hey everyone what's up welcome to
simulation we are currently sitting down
at women in tech international and we
are sitting down with Tamara Thomsen
hello hello thanks for having me
thanks for coming on the show appreciate
it I really appreciate it
so we are gonna talk about serious take
productions you've been doing that for
about six and a half years now yes I
started the company about 2011 and it
grew from there it started more on the I
went to film school the CLR Institute
and I actually went into a corporate
field after that where I produced for
corporate clients such as Microsoft and
Starbucks and then also for another
corporate company where I came in where
there were only eight employees starting
and they're an online educational
platform for physical therapists and
chiropractors where I came in and
created a whole new vision for their
brands for videos for their whole
training system and they're the number
one company in their week now in Seattle
and they have over 95 employees but I
helped create their vision to make their
videos less boring more creative and
shorter segments so that people were
stayed intrigued with their actual video
content from there when I was working
those jobs I was hustling to start my
own business at the same time so I was
that entrepreneur freelancer whatever
you call it from the beginning and then
yeah just basically separated myself
after that point and just went full
force entrepreneur into my own brand how
did you know what exactly would be the
best sort of content to make to inspire
exactly what they needed at those
companies so I won't go into my full
deep backstory but I have a very deep
story myself and I share this through
different interviews as well as from
stages of my why and why I started
sharing inspiring compelling content
that was also creative and so there's a
point in my life where I just was really
bored with things and as a filmmaker I'm
now currently directing my fourth
documentary film
through that the process though like you
wouldn't believe it but I started off a
and YouTube Wow let's backtrack I
started off seven years old my dad
bought me not me but the family at camp
corner and I started filming silly
videos like jumping on the couch - you
know glycerine by bush and away cysts
and all these different things creating
silly videos and I always looked at it
as a hobby and later on in life I
decided that it was inspired by people
my family they said why don't you make
it a career and I said for another four
years I said no it's just a hobby just
hobby started a YouTube channel when
YouTube came out in 2005 and I had over
800,000 views on my channel and I ended
up deleting it because at the time I
thought I don't want to be seen as a
silly girl that was making Blair Witch
three like mock-ups to like singing with
her hairbrush dancing around the bedroom
whatever it looked like at 25 years old
I was just singing dancing and I started
watching documentary films and I always
correlated documentaries as being boring
as a kid because the ones that they
would show us in school like weren't
always entertaining they're just all
factual and the visuals weren't always
compelling to me and so I always had
this thought in my head that these were
boring but then I started actually going
to film festivals in my 20s and I got
really intrigued by them because I
started seeing short films and
documentaries that I'm like wow these
aren't boring just wanna stay with that
childhood jumping on the couch and they
were taking that and then having a
hairbrush and taking that because that's
really important to fostering kids
mm-hmm ya know being able to do
something but my family being able to
encourage me to know that I could create
something as a career versus it being a
hobby because you want to be able to
turn your passion to profit and that's
what I was able to do through serious
take productions and but the reasoning
of why I called it series tape
productions was because after going
through that YouTube experience I wanted
people to take me more seriously and so
that's where that came from
it's too bad you should
worth it no after the time frame of it
when you could bring it back but I did I
did extract some of the videos I did
keep some of them and I do share them at
events and I get people to laugh because
I like doing weird stuff like singing on
a flip phone to Numa Numa song you know
do another slowly Stefan it gets people
to laugh but also shows a different side
of me because I'm very witty and I like
to have fun and but I also like to have
a serious side of me where I'm the
professional on set I love to direct I
love to oversee things I love to bring
other people's passion to profit for
their brands and that's why brand
storytelling is really important to us
through serious hit productions and so
that's kind of where that started and
led out into different connections
because I'm all about making meaningful
connections with the right people to
help build strong referral partners to
you know clients for life and to be able
to impact more people more often and so
yeah it's just been I've just been
really grateful for being able to build
this business and I still keep going
strong I wonder what else are like let's
stay with your with your story for a
little bit longer is there seem to be a
lot of people now on YouTube that are
totally eccentric and the most novel
trying to be and that seems to be a
style that is now accepted totally
accepted thing okay and I wonder how
often kids go through the process of
being normalized by culture and losing
that sort of creative spirit and I think
it's maybe it's something it's slowly
increasing like the amount of you just
be as a novel and unique as you want to
be but there's still that pressure from
culture as well yeah no I mean I
actually know quite a few
entrepreneurial friends that actually
encourage their like preteens and
teenagers to like step out and create
their own YouTube channels and then come
their own creatives at a young age but
you also have to look at it a sense that
you can find so much different type of
content online and there there's going
to
other types of videos and crude content
out there that I'd be like I wouldn't
want to show this to my my kid or
encourage them to create these things or
go out there and I even know a friend of
mine we were just talking about this the
other day her brothers created a channel
just specifically to go out and do
stupid things and get attention that way
you know and which is fine but you know
at this point youtube is so
oversaturated the ones that didn't get
in like ten years ago or something like
it's a little bit harder to to start and
grow I've seen people do it like they've
grown a million over 18 months but you
have to be unique but you have to be
yourself at the same time so because if
you start going out there and just
trying to be like somebody else or
trying to mimic somebody else that's
like oh this big YouTube sensation is
rocking it I'm gonna be I'm gonna do
just what they do you're still you and
there's still them so if you're not
focusing on being you and be able to
create content consistently because
these youtubers I have friends that make
tens of thousands of dollars a month on
YouTube but that they've also stated how
it's starting to slow down for them
because they're trying to pump out like
three to five videos they have to create
three to five videos a week to keep the
consistency flowing and the even the the
cash payout now is a little bit
different than it was like five years
ago they're like making millions you
know or you know whatever they're
looking at so it's very intriguing to me
so those that are really stepping into
the YouTube space just need to think how
can I get creative how can I step out
more and how can I inspire others do
they want to like subscribe share so
that's what we're doing through our
channel we're creating a whole new
playlist for our broadcast year
Authority brand sub brand under serious
take where we are able to help empower
more women so I'm interviewing women but
we're also creating the creative content
that goes with that because storytelling
is key creative visuals be able to keep
people's attention in like 3 to 10
seconds and not losing them you have to
keep them on there is it text that's
added to your video is it music that
strikes emotion which is key if you
don't have music somewhere in your video
you know like if it's an interviews
based like that's that can
fine but if you're showing other types
of video make sure there's music in
there that strikes emotion because
that's very keep it being able to choose
the right music for that moment in time
for that type of video it's important
too but people just need to think I hate
using the word think out of the box but
it's true
it's just not a big term for me but
maybe you should stay on some of these
concepts that you just laid out thank
you guys embody so we have in order to
best story tell you there's usually the
strong consideration for music there's a
strong consideration for emotion a
strong consideration for communicating
the information in a way that's fun and
engaging inspirational exactly so we
always tell our clients so it's all
about the key messaging because
everybody has a story but everyone has
multiple stories to share so what is
that that fine story that's going to be
you that's gonna be that's gonna attract
your ideal audience so I can turn around
and tell an example I've been able to
speak on stages about multiple types of
content right so I won't go into deep
diving into a story but one story I will
share deep dives and tells about how I'm
in December I will be 8 years sober
that's gonna attract a certain type of
individual and crowd that's gonna come
up to me and inspire being like wow you
know what they're gonna open up to me
and say you know what I have two years
sober or I've been struggling or
something and that's that's gonna bring
that vibe because I'm inspiring people
by that particular story and then I can
tell you like so here I am and you know
last year I spoke on stage with Marcus
lemonis from CNBC's the Prophet people
are like wow how did you get in touch
with Marcus lemonis how did you get that
opportunity and I tell them it's about
building relationships being very
persistent and be able to think how can
I get their attention and how can I
provide value to them before anything
else yep because there's no reason why
they need to know me right so that's one
story and then you know maybe it's
another story about how I'm you know
creating still a youtube videos
you know in my past something fun and
silly people be like yeah we think we
really need to stay on that providing
other people with value that is very
lost in the me culture and when we
approach people and we offer them value
right away it shows that we are selfless
and that we're doing it because we care
about their goals and that that's why
we're doing it and then in if they don't
reciprocate then usually we move on as
well but usually people do reciprocate
and then it builds a really good
relationship in that sense where you're
helping each other with your goals well
it's also something that can help on the
side of like a business relationship
when someone knows that you're genuinely
wanting to help and you have the same
mission
so like Marcus lemonis you know people
process product you know but people come
first right and that's something that's
very important to me to be able to
provide an experience for our clients or
referrals or friends or partners whoever
it is like it's all about the people and
how we can provide them the best
experience of knowing what they're there
they're going to go through through an
experience as well and so finding those
people that are in alignment with you be
able to give them as much value I tend
to give give give my partner tends to
say stop giving so much you know but I
always say well at this point I just
want to keep giving because it's gonna
reciprocate with the right people yeah
and I even had a Facebook message the
other day so when we're recording this
female empowerment project
let's gal wrote me a private message
afterwards and she said I just want you
to know I was just talking to my husband
about you and she was like and I just
lit up because I thought to myself
you're one of the real ones you're
genuinely a good person and she was like
because there's so many people in this
entrepreneur space that are just takers
and I've found those people as well and
but you learned through experiences and
you have to let go of that you know
can't hold grudges and things like you
know when you finish a meeting with
somebody and you
action item list and sometimes you'll
have some action items and they'll have
some action items my goal is to always
finish my action items before them and
then I message them and I'm like here's
here's a reminder for the action items
here there's an easy blurb about what we
do so that you can make those
connections easier so you know you're
not you're not gym and you give them the
yeah and it's always interesting to see
who can reciprocate how quickly and
usually it ends up really leading to
powerful connections between these
people I didn't know each other in the
past
yeah I've been able to build some really
strong relationships with people through
social media that I never met obviously
I mean that's the power of social media
being able to create these relationships
with people and then finally meet them
in person a year two years later maybe
they live in Australia then you're all
of a sudden speaking at their event or
you know doing something with them or
for them and their purpose and it's just
intriguing to me that they were able to
do that because ten years ago we
couldn't really do do much of that we're
just starting to learn and you know
first it was MySpace and then it was
Facebook and then you know YouTube and
and so these platforms are growing and
now it like LinkedIn you know there's
different ways to utilize each platform
at the right way to help build your
brand and business now when it comes to
highlighting women that are
entrepreneurs are is there a certain way
of doing that that that catalyzes a
stronger efficiency we're doing so so
yeah so we work with a lot of female
entrepreneurs coaches consultants
speakers storytellers and it's been it's
been very intriguing because they're all
passionate about doing something of a
higher purpose for themselves that are
going to help other people and those are
dutiful that we drive and those are the
people that we empower and so it's been
really intriguing because you have I
don't call it
I've been able to connect with the ones
that I call mission-driven and then the
people that come into my life that are
money driven my mission is to have
passion to profit because not everyone
can see how they can do that but I start
to align with more of the women that
really are strong in alignment with
their mission obviously their end goal
is to make money through this process
but they'll do anything they can do at
that moment to make sure that they can
get to that point that they want to be
because there's a lot of greedy people
out there as well and so it's just like
you have to find your tribe you know who
you can connect with and so it's been
really interesting working so I'd say
like 98% of the people that that we work
with know like and trust and then
there's the 2% that have come through
that of course we can't connect with
everybody and it's just not going to be
an alignment so there's been stressful
situations where you just have to make
that decision to let go of that even if
it means a large chunk of money like
I've had people that have held on to
clients but they don't enjoy working
with them and if you don't enjoy working
with them it can put a emotional stress
on yourself and then you can start
seeing that and then your overall health
can can start to tyranny and that has
happened in the past but working with
women has been really inspiring for me
because we work with male and females
but as we started this this movement to
help women broadcast their authority
more through the media videos live
streaming YouTube and from the stage
it's just cool to see more women come
together because there's all these
statistics out there of you know I can't
recall all the exact statistics but the
side of like only a certain amount like
a very small amount of women
entrepreneurs hitting their first six
figures in their business - you know
what is the only 5% hit like seven
figures or whatever it is and the
entrepreneur space is very
male-dominated you know and and I want
to be able to help more women we need
men in our lives to help help us grow
there's mentors friends that I know like
entrust and I speak on their stages and
but there's just I want to give more
opportunity men as well because men
significant
overall in their ability to feel and and
have control their emotions as well at
times get away from logic and focus on
love sometimes you know these types of
things and like you said - yeah even
even in video so like with us being a
female owned video production company
you know it does have the pros for some
of the women sometimes and I'm not
saying that men don't don't see certain
things but there will be you know like a
situation like fixing the angle of a
camera or you know something like the
lighting might be different or making
sure that the shadows on somebody's face
or a double chin or you know anything
that can make or asking a woman like do
you have a good side I said I'd tell you
this is my good side this I would have
chosen this chair anyways yeah so things
like that that people don't really think
about cuz they're like this looks good
but you need to make sure that the
female that's in that chair if you're
videotaping them it is an alignment with
how your thoughts are and always ask
their opinion that's that's what we've
been able to produce videos from in
there like like yeah I like this you
like this sometimes you don't want to
like do that because then you give them
like the option open but I think it's
important because if they come back with
a product and they're like I look fat or
I you know I don't like that at least
you've given them the opportunity to see
it yeah there's also the [ __ ] ship it
mentality as well so because the the
idea of opening up the door to an hour
of shifting around and trying to do
things right but at the same time like
you said is so important to actually
have content that the person aligns
themselves to it so to ask and that's
that's an aspect of emotional
intelligence to get somebody in a
comfortable state worried perfectionist
onset sometimes professors can be very
annoying as well it's like it does get
the content out there so that you
mentioned this and I think this is so
crucial the amount of women that are in
positions of executive ownership or
entrepreneurship inside of companies
especially of higher level companies or
even their own companies is is is is low
right now and we would like it to be
higher there's so much beautiful
intelligence and also ideas that can be
formulated through women into the world
and organizations like Witte really help
us get there production Studios like
yours help us get there now there also
seems to be this like very interesting
tendency for for women to really want to
focus on their family and also for men
to just like want to sacrifice whatever
is going on in their life to try and
like climb up this race in order to try
and become more wanted and so it's just
this like very strange cultural system
what do you think about that cultural
system how can it get a little shifting
Swift taking the but in order to you
know to change things up a bit really
depends on the family in the system and
what's going on there so you have your
stay-at-home moms you have your mom
preneur is you have your women in
corporate you have your stay-at-home
dads now which I know quite a few where
it's been this kind of shift over the
past like decade of like what the roles
are in in a household I think when men
and women are in relationships or
marriage or have kids like you want to
support the other person and always ask
like what is it that they're passionate
about that they want to do as well so
you can support either way so that the
male doesn't feel like they have to
climb this ladder you know themselves or
if there's a mom that wants to be a mom
preneur and help build a business from
online at home to help support the
family as well and not just be a
stay-at-home mom and solely depend on
the male there's so many different
different ways to think about that to be
honest so I'm glad you're unpacking it
with that amount of nuance because
that's it is what it is it's our social
fabric it's the human experiment and it
has all that and you wants and I think
it's crucial to talk about it because I
think we can buy an unhappy happy to
because I think people get lost and like
growing old together and then they
forget what their values are or just why
they were why they married in the first
place and then all of a sudden ten
years pass and then all of a sudden
you're not having a conversation about
why you're doing what you're doing are
you passionate about it well now they're
saying eighty-five percent of the
workforce is disengaged or doesn't like
their Jo B I'm like if you don't like
your job find something else that you're
more passionate about at least try
something else I know it takes time it's
not like doesn't always happen overnight
for everybody because it's very
competitive out there but I always say
like just because I have been able to
build a successful brand starting off
working full time for a corporate
company and start my own business on the
side where is working 60 to 80 hours
like that
hustle stage starts with entrepreneurs
first and if you have that then you want
to lead and shift into now you K you're
hustling you're like okay now when is
the time it's never a right time to let
go of the corporate job but if that's
what you're really trying to do like
figure out a way if you're the type of
person that needs stability then you're
packing away you know cash in the bank
for a while before you let go or if
you're someone like me I'm like okay I'm
just gonna jump in I'm just gonna have
faith and trust that I can build and
grow this and have the support of my
partner and those other people around me
because I'm the type of person that will
be like okay my backs up against the
wall now what I'm not gonna quit I'm
just gonna keep figuring things out you
know and that's kind of just how my
mentality is but not everyone's like
that
because I've seen a lot of entrepreneurs
that even were in mastermind groups with
myself where it's almost this
picture-perfect life that everyone's
like yeah we're doing this thing and
then people may not be truthful with
themselves or other people because you
need the support of other people to help
keep you strong through the hardships of
entrepreneurship as well and then all of
a sudden I hear that you know Joe or Bob
or sue is also back in corporate but
maybe not necessarily because I wanted
to but because they wanted the stability
you know coming in so there's so much to
do with entrepreneurship so I go off on
tangents
well you're explaining all these
different ways that entrepreneurship
manifests itself throughout the social
fabric that we have and
the unpacking the nuance of the roles
that we have as we grew up from a kid
that's bouncing around on the bed and
couch and doing the the hair comb
singing yeah exactly so we have we have
everything from from that fostering that
as kids and having a community and
family that helps us foster that all the
way to when I was totally 25 years old
and I was doing that part retaining the
childhood through adulthood and then
also when we do get to a later stage in
life where were maybe when we're just
graduating high school or when we're
getting out of college or and where have
entered the workforce and we're finding
out about ourselves and the way we
engage with people but are still finding
out themselves like I don't know your
opinion on this but I think that we are
so young going in from high school to
college it's just kind of this thing
like this American Way that like that's
when I grew up that was kind of what was
seen like where are you going to school
like what's your 4-year University and I
decided not to I decided to actually go
to Community College where I loved
basketball and my dream at that time was
playing the WNBA and so I played
basketball in college and got a
scholarship that way and went to a
community college and then from there I
didn't know where I wanted to go then
because I was a creative so I started
doing stuff in graphic design and then I
switched over to like early childhood
education I didn't ever find what I
wanted to do but I was always on the
side making silly videos later on
realizing and it's so important to
actually have all the different
opportunities that both a man woman a
person of color anywhere around the
world that you're being born no matter
what socioeconomic status to have
opportunity to be able to pick up a
computer and learn how to design or code
to be able to pick up anything and put
your hands on it and start working with
it and get an experience or learning
from that so as we build out this
this world around us what are maybe the
seas are a couple questions we typically
ask on our show is what are you what
would you say are some of these
important principles that we add into
the society that we have now of how do
we maybe do things like maximize the
potential of everyone that is birthed
into the world well it's different for
everyone so I would say basically I
literally just tell everyone you know if
there's something that you're really
passionate about like if you think that
you can't turn it into a career
think again because there's always new
ways to think and with the online world
and online marketing in different ways
you can always now you can create
products out of things and people don't
even think about that like there's a lot
of people that haven't been introduced
to the entrepreneurial space yet or
YouTube or Facebook marketing or
anything that they really think about
some people are constantly looking at
Facebook stories Instagram stories and
you know but I just always encourage
people to if they really want to create
something themselves you know start but
also look into finding out or following
someone subscribe to a YouTube channel
that you can learn from somebody or when
you get to a point hire your first
mentor or a business coach or life coach
or whatever you need marketing coach but
I just really encourage people to to do
that because it's just we can't just go
on living life like feeling you know
empty
basically oh man that was real that end
point that really hit me strong feeling
empty because that is what sometimes we
feel when we don't have a family or
community or a passion that's actualized
within us and sometimes we don't realize
that we're empty man
so yeah turning passion and profit that
was a really interesting I like that a
lot
so let's ask you a couple more of these
questions on the way out these are some
fun questions what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
traveling why because once I started
traveling I was able to see so much more
out there than what what has I've been
grown up with only in the u.s. so last
year I traveled to Santorini I traveled
to Athens Greece
I traveled to Rome I traveled to Ireland
and I also traveled to Iceland last year
but being able to go out there and as
well as record video content pull out my
selfie drone flying it over you know
icebergs to you know oceans to the
Cliffs of Moher like I was able to to
see things in person and like you see
things in videos all the time and that's
what we're really good at like visual
storytelling but be able to see you know
all their cultures out there and and
just know that there's so much more to
the world out there that people need to
see and it just encourages me to travel
more so now I'm gonna be going to
Scotland and I love seeing castles and
all the fun stuff and and I would go see
like a Loch Ness you know all these
things like these fairy tales and fables
and things like that but be able to see
things like that come to life because I
watch other people just live through
their lives and all they do is get up
and they go through their job and they
come home and then they they have their
meal with their family and they spend
time with their kids and then it's like
they watch their favorite show and then
it's you know bedtime stories and then
they just continuously do this and this
and that there's so much more to life
out there to be able to to see and I
know it's hard for people because they
have families they have kids and there
are budgets but I just encourage anyone
out there to just travel at least once
there's at least once find something
that you think's beautiful put it on
your vision board and go after it
like say I'm gonna go to Hawaii even if
it's Hawaii it doesn't have to be out of
the country it's a beautiful space other
than the volcanoes going off
no but you know what I mean like it's
just I said it gold to something I'm
like I'm gonna do that and I do it but
sometimes it takes a little longer to
get there but you know offbeat Road
I imagined people putting up where they
want to travel to upon their vision
board when you said that and then I just
yeah I still create vision boards and I
recreate them every six months because
I've passed those goals again like it's
it's so crazy how your mindset and you
know being able to visualize something
people don't understand that the energy
is out there you set the intention and
the energy out there and it's crazy what
life can bring you like I just you know
yeah the intention and the energy and
helps with the manifestation absolutely
yeah and there's so many things outside
of the three-dimensional reality that we
live in that we don't understand jack
[ __ ] about well and then you can go into
VR and we can go places you know and and
but I do like in person like being able
to feel that experience energy smell
that ocean of somewhere else like like
I'm I'm put I'm on my list of places ago
so in November I'm going to Lisbon but
I'm setting it on this goal to be able
to go step over in Croatia cuz I like a
big fan of Game of Thrones so I want to
go like check out like these link spaces
I'm like this was on TV I want to go see
this this is beautiful you know I'm
gonna make a happen so stuff like that
but just I just encourage people like
just put something into your mind and
just go after it do you think we're
alone in the cosmos
[Music]
[Laughter]
well like it I've definitely believe in
higher beings and I also believe in
there's so much more to the world and
the galaxies out there like honestly
think think of this so there's planet
Earth and there's all these other
planets and galaxies out there and how
could we be alone like really how could
we be alone you know we can all believe
what we want to believe but there's I've
had experiences in my faith I've had
experiences my mom's experiences with
UFOs that's another story
yeah so this is intriguing so my mom is
sticks to her guns with it and so does
my late grandmother and hurt one of her
best friends but so my mom was in her
her early 20s and her friend Charlie and
her we're driving between Nevada and
Mount Shasta and it was late at night
and they said they said they hadn't been
drinking they weren't intoxicated her on
any form of drugs or anything like that
that's like okay mom but she's so set
she's very stubborn and she's very much
when she sees something it's it's there
and so I'm like okay if you say that's
what you saw so you saw so she's been
telling this for years but she was they
were driving back through that area
there was no cars no lights nothing and
then they turn around they said that
they both have told the same story and I
don't see why they would lie together
they saw a light an object that was just
hovering above the road that was in
front of them and it was just there just
hovering circular shift would you would
say or object and so all of a sudden
they're driving and then they look in
front of them and then there's a man
just walking down the street in the
middle of the road only wearing a
t-shirt and pants no shoes no socks
nothing and they said he just looked
completely out of
and they decided to just drive right by
him they were so frightened that they
were like we're not gonna stop then they
looked up and then the the object was
gone and they looked in the back of the
mirror and they didn't see the man
walking on the the road I had a lot of
goosebumps here my mom said I'm like oh
my goodness but it similar situation
happened supposedly with her and her mom
driving through the same area when they
took a trip when she was a teenager when
she was younger so I was like her mom
yeah and so they both my my mom my
grandmother's not here to vouch for it
now but I know that Beth started but
pass along so it was very interesting to
me and I know I've seen things on untap
loads and things happen to people but I
definitely believe there's other forces
and beings out there I just really don't
feel like we're alone and the way that
they could be manipulating pulling the
strings of what's going on is so
interesting you never know you never
know
well maybe we will one day figure it out
so do you think we're in a computer
simulation do i we should be we're not
no space reality hmm are you throwing me
off yeah no no I really I really enjoyed
it as we got into flow it felt really
good talking about you know talking
about you and talking about what you
care about and why you care about it I
don't know anything about you I do my
research
oh yeah yeah well we'll definitely
message you the content the link when
it's ready and you know we love bringing
on different leaders across the world
and we love asking them about what
future they're building but also these
may be tougher questions about what we
do bye max might even potential what do
we do about globalization about wealth
and equality about artificial general
intelligence about all these different
reasons
things that are going on in our future
and how do we make sure that kids that
are being born into the world today and
tomorrow that they get to be actualized
well it's very intriguing though because
the way that I was raised you know I was
you know in high school it was dial-up
AOL and then now we have high-speed
Internet phone access all these things
and so it's very different for me and
then the way that kids are growing up
now I do think that it's a little bit
more interesting because we hadn't used
to have to pick up a phone to call and
actually have conversations with people
and now everyone's so technology-based
and they don't communicate here we have
all these emojis and everything else the
world and so it's just different but I
think that as people grow into these
different generations like with
technology and other things like it's
just going to kind of mold with how it's
supposed to be molded to how it's
supposed to be yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean we're the ones in Emily that are
making our own lives living our own
lives to the fullest and taking
advantage of you know learning
technology or sharing video content or
creating our own shows or traveling or
whatever that looks like but people can
sit there and be inspired and watch
video content from us and then never
take actions we always tell people at
the end of the show to create with this
content afterward we always recommend
that okay that's one of my big things I
take action take action I feel as though
a little bit more conversation about
ethics and about but about philosophy
are really important as we go into this
integration with technology in our
future so what a blast it's been talking
thanks for having me this has been so
much fun
thank you yeah and we'll catch you soon
thank you everyone for tuning in thank
you
if you guys had a good time make sure
you give us a comment below with your
thoughts you give us a subscribe give us
a like also consider building with this
go do it go make something with this go
write about it make a video about it go
and interview someone about it
importance of storytelling importance of
emotion importance of music as you
portray
storytelling and get people excited
about content in the world so thanks
everyone for tuning in and we'll catch
you soon
you